نقل موقع والا الاسرائيلي ان ثلاثه وزراء
من حزب المعسكر بزعامه بني جانس لم
يشاركوا في جلسه الحكومه بسبب ما وصفوه
بالتهجم على رئيس الاركان كما عبر
169 من القاده العسكريين الاسرائيليين
السابقين في رساله نشرتها وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه عن دعمهم لرئيس الاركان هيرتس
هاليفي في وجه هجمات بعض الوزراء عليه بعد
فتحه تحقيقا في هجوم السابع من
اكتوبر معنا الان من القدس الدكتور محمد
هلسه الاكاديمي والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور اذا هذه
الخلافات اين وصلت
برايك
اي الاصطفاف
بات نق ليلى واضحا في داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي المعسكرات باتت اكثر وضوحا في
مواقفها وما عاد الالتباس يحكم الموقف لدى
الجمهور الاسرائيلي الامتناع ثلاثه وزراء
وعلى راسهم رئيس المعسكر الوطني جنس شخصيا
وايزن كوت ركنين مهمين في كابنه الحرب من
حضور اجتماع موسع للحكومه هذا ينقل الخلاف
الى درجه اعلى الى مستوى اعلى باتت
التصريحات والمواقف ايضا ليست فقط
التصريحات هي التي تحكم سلوك القياده
السياسيه في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي لم
يكن من بد امام جانتس وايزن كوت امام
الهجمه التي شنت على هيرتس هاليفي رئيس
هيئه الاركان الا اتخاذ هذه المواقف
للظهور بموقف القوي القادر على اتخاذ
مواقف و يعني التمنع هذا الصوت الصوت الذي
يمثل مؤسسه الجيش امام الهجوم الحاد الذي
يتخذه اليمين الاسرائيلي بتحريك من
نتنياهو اي هذه المواقف التي يتخذها جانتس
ويتخذها شركاؤه ايضا كما قلنا يمثلون صوت
الجيش هي تاتي لمحاوله صد ومنع تغول
اليمين الاسرائيلي على الجيش وعلى هرتس
هليفي الرساله التي اراد هؤلاء صالحه هو
انه لن يسمحوا باستمرار التهجم على مؤسسه
الجيش وعلى الجيش وبانهم يعني ما زالوا
عند مواقفهم باقين في اي كابنه الحرب
وسيتصدى
هل الرساله يعني قويه بما يكفي لتحدث
تغييرا حقيقيا برايك في المدى
القصير مازال الموقف الاستراتيجي العام
لدى جنتس بالبقاء في داخل كبنه الحرب مع
كل الاصوات التي تنادي بضروره خروجه او
حتى تلك الاصوات التي تدفعه للخروج كما هو
الحال مع بينغ فير و سموتريتش الذين
بالتاكيد يرغبان في رؤيه كبنه الحرب يتفكك
لكن اعتبارات المصلحه الاستراتيجيه العامه
ل ايزنكوت شخصيا وجانتس هي في البقاء في
داخل كابنت الحرب لمحاوله التاثير من
الداخل لانه ثبت لديهما بان التاثير من
الداخل هو يعني اكبر والمصلحه التي يجني
انها كمعسكر وطني من الداخل هي اكبر وهذا
قلناه كثيرا استطلاعات الراي منحتهما تفوق
كبير في الاصوات على نتنياهو و على
الليكود بشكل خاص لكن مدى مقدرته على
البقاء هذا منوط بطبيعه تطورات الميدان
التي تنعكس ايضا على الحاله الداخليه
السياسيه في داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي
وماذا مقدرت نتنياهو على استمرار المناوره
والهروب الى الامام وعلى مدى مقدرت
نتنياهو ايضا على استمرار الموائمه ما بين
رغبته في استمرار ائتلافه في البقاء لانه
يتكي عليه ولا حكومه دون هذا الائتلاف
اليميني ورغبته ايضا في استمرار كابنه
الحرب لاعتبارات يعني الثقه التي يمنحها
له الجمهور من خلال وجود شخصيات وازنه
كجنس وز زن كوت لهما خبره طويله وياتي من
مؤسسه الجيش وهما رؤساء اركان سابقين
وايضا وزراء حرب سابقون وبالتالي نتنياهو
بحاجه اليهما ليمرر مشهد الثقه الذي يعني
يريد ان يصوره للمجتمع الاسرائيلي في
اداره هذه الحرب من دونهما بالتاكيد س
يعني يكون وضع نتنياهو محرج مع وجود هؤلاء
الصبيا كما يسميهم المجتمع الاسرائيلي
عدمي الخبره وياتون من خلفيه سياسيه يعني
عديمه الخبره في اداره ال شؤون البلد وقد
قال بعض الوزراء تبعنا الاعلام الاسرائيلي
اليوم وقد قال بعض الوزراء الذين حضروا
الاجتماع العاصف الذي حدث بالامس بانه
لديهما شك من ان هذه الحكومه قادره على
اداره شؤون البلاد واداره الحرب التي تجري
حاليا مع وجود مثل هذه الشخصيات التي تشن
يعني هجوما كاسحا على الجيش وعلى قاده
الجيش وعلى هدسه ليفي تحديدا في اوج
المعركه ولم يشت يعني يعتد المجتمع
الاسرائيلي على ظهور مثل هذه الاصوات
الناقده التي يعني تبحث في اخفاقات وفي
يعني توقع الملامه
وعلى بلا شك دكتور محمد بلا شك الداخل
الاسرائيلي يراقب هذه الخلافات عن كثب
ولكن هناك اعين خارجيه ايضا تراقب ما يجري
داخل اسرائيل وخصوصا اداره بايدن تحديدا
التي اعطت نتنياهو كل الدعم الذي طلب به
الان هل لمست وهل تتوقع اي تغيير بناء على
ما سمعناه من بلينكن اليوم في الدوحه او
ما نتوقعه من جولته في
المنطقه اولا الموقف الامريكي ويعني دعونا
نكون واضحين في هذه المساله الموقف
الامريكي هو موقف استراتيجي وليس تكتيكي
من العلاقه مع الاسرائيلي تاريخيا منذ
اقامه هذا الكيان ومع كل الادارات ومع كل
رؤساء الاداره الامريكيه ظل ثابتا لم
يتغير استمرار التغطيه واستمرار توفير
المظله لاسرائيل سياسي ودبلوماسي وفي
المحافل الدوليه وعسكري ايضا
لكن وكان الاداره الامريكيه اليوم تقع بين
فكي كماش استمرار التعاطي المطلق مع
اسرائيل ورغباتها يسبب لها الاحراج على
المستوى الدولي ويسبب لها الخساره ايضا في
الداخل الامريكي وقد اظهرت استطاعه الراي
يعني موقف الناخبين من بايدن شخصيا والحزب
الديمقراطي وهذا تقرا الولايات المتحده
لذلك هي تحاول ان تظهر بمظهر يعني ولو في
الاطار الشكلي المنتقد لسلوك اسرائيل
وتحاول ان تركز على جانبين الانسان
والمساعدات ل وتجنب قتل المدنيين كما
تسميهم في داخل قطاع غزه لمحاوله الظهور
يعني بمظهر وكانه يعني هنالك عسكريين او
مدنيين يقتلوا في قطاع غزه والتعامي عن
حاله الاجرام والمذابح التي تجري هناك لكن
ايضا في الجهه المقابله الولايات المتحده
تعتقد بان الظهور بلاغ كبيره جدا امام
الاداره الاسرائيليه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
قد تسبب لها ايضا خساره كبيره في الداخل
الامريكي خاصه مع سطوه اللوبي الصهيوني في
داخل المتحده وقد راينا اول امس كيف ان
رئيسه جامعه هارفد قد قدمت استقالتها
نتيجه الضغوطات التي مورث بسبب مواقف يعني
شكليه كلاميه صدرت هنا وهناك لذلك تخشى
الاداره الامريكيه من ان ظهورها بمظهر
الداع يعني الواقف ضد الرغبات الاسرائيليه
ربما ايضا يسبب لها الخساره لذلك ادت
واستبدلت واستبدلت بشخص يعني واضح في
انتباه
الصهيونيه هذا كان يعني رساله قويه ايضا
بلا شك
بالتاكيد لذلك يعني اداره بايدن وكل
الممثلين الاداره الامريكيه القادمون الى
المنطقه في حجيج هذا الى اسرائيل يفهمون
بانه مواجهه الرغبات الاسرائيليه قد تودي
او تؤدي بخسائر اكبر او قول لا واضحه
كبيره جدا لاسرائيل قد تؤدي الى خسائر
كبيره ايضا للاداره الامريكيه في اطار
الداخل الامريكي لذلك ربما تلجا ال
الولايات المتحده كبديل عن التماهي المطلق
واللا المطلقه الى اللا الخجوله اللا
التدريجيه اللا البطيئه اللا الغير ظاهره
التي تبدو في موقفها من ما يجري في في
المنطقه من خلال بعض المواقف التي تحاول
من خلالها ثني اسرائيل عن استمرار الذهاب
الى هذه المواجهه وربما ما يعني نشر اليوم
في صحيفه الواشنطن بوست عن مخاوف قيادات
امريكيه من ان نتنياهو قد يذهب الى جر
المنطقه الى مواجهه مع حزب الله نظرا
للاعتبارات الشخصيه ربما من خلال بعض
المواقف التي تظهر هنا وهناك تحاول
الاداره الامريكيه تح الداخلي الاسرائيلي
وتذكري اخت ليلى بان ما دالت الاداره
الامريكيه تصر على وجود او يعني تفضل وجود
جانتس في داخل كابينه الحر بمحاوله ضبط
الايقاع وسلوك نتنياهو تحديدا في هذه
المواجهه وهي ترى ضروره وجوده ويقال بانه
جانس هو الشخص الذي يعني تراهن عليه
الولايات المتحده لقياده المشهد السياسي
الاسرائيلي ما بعد الحرب او ما بعد
نتنياهو ان امكن ازاحه نتنياهو هذا اليمين
القومي من المشهد السياسي الاسرائيلي لكن
الامر مازال يعني المشهد فيه ملتبس حتى
على الاداره الامريكيه وهذه الضبابيه تحكم
ايضا ومرتبط بشكل كبير بما يجري في
الميدان بلا شك دكتور محمد هلسه الاكاديمي
والخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اشكرك
جزيلا كنت معنا من القدس